Ein Hof am See:
Sylvia und Markus Buob
suchen die Ruhe in Schweden.
Sie wollen dort
Ferienwohnungen vermieten.
Viva México:
Stefano Lotti und Stefano Navarretta
zieht es in die Karibik.
Im Land des Tequila
wittern sie ihre Chance.
Und Familie Tokay möchte sich
in Südafrika neu erfinden.
Ihr Traum: eine eigene Lodge.
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
Sylvia und Markus Buob müssen
in die Frauenklinik zur Kontrolle.
Vámonos.
Wie?
- Vámonos.
Sylvia
ist im sechsten Monat schwanger.
Es soll ihr letzter Arztbesuch sein,
bevor es nach Schweden geht.
Soll ich noch Wasser lösen?
Ich könnte jetzt nämlich gleich.
Ich gebe Ihnen den Becher.
Kennen Sie den Ablauf? - Ja, danke.
Den Urin dort hinstellen
und danach Platz nehmen.
Vielen Dank.
- Merci.
Ausgerechnet in dem Moment,
als sie den Termin der Auswanderung
festlegten, wurde Sylvia schwanger.
Das ist ein grosses Geschenk.
Nach allem, was passiert ist,
wissen wir dass Kinder
keine Selbstverständlichkeit sind.
Und jetzt geniessen wir es,
in unser Traumland zu gehen.
Es sind zwei grosse Ereignisse,
die wir mit Freude entgegennehmen.
Daher sollte man nie einen Gedanken
verschieben,
sondern: Jetzt erst recht.
Tag, ausgepinkelt?
Ja, ich habe mit der Hebamme
noch Small Talk gemacht. - Schön.
Die Ärzte müssen regelmässig schauen,
ob es dem Baby gut geht.
Sylvia
hatte bereits drei Fehlgeburten.
* Schwermütige, angespannte Klänge *
Bist du nervös?
- Was? Nein, ich doch nicht.
Ich versuche,
den Puls runterzufahren.
Aber das Grundgefühl ist gut.
Das Grundgefühl ist positiv.
- Ja.
Kommt schon gut.
Ja.
Frau Buob?
- Grüezi, Herr Uerlings.
Guten Tag. Wie geht's?
Danke, gut. Bis jetzt.
* Sie lachen. *
Perfekt, dann dürfen Sie
gerne reingehen und Platz nehmen.
Mit dem Ultraschall
zeigt Dr. Uerlings,
wie sich das Baby seit der
letzten Untersuchung entwickelt hat.
So. Dann starten wir.
Wenn man den Schallkopf so hält,
sieht man die Wirbelsäule.
Man hat da eine wunderschöne
Darstellung vom Profil:
Nase, Nasenbein. Kinn.
So.
Dann schauen wir das Herz an.
Es ist ganz, ganz gut.
Für mich ist immer das Schönste,
wenn man das Herz schlagen sieht,
dass es lebt
oder dass es sich bewegt.
Es ist natürlich schon
ein unglaubliches Gefühl.
Auch, dass es jetzt
in einem drin wachsen darf.
Und darum, glaube ich, ist dies
für uns das schönste Erlebnis.
Mir ist - blöd gesagt -
alles andere mehr oder weniger egal.
Ich wartete nur,
bis ich den Herzschlag sah.
Alles andere ist jetzt Zugabe.
* Gefühlvolle Klaviermusik *
Alles in Ordnung -
aus Sicht des Arztes
können die drei losziehen,
ins neue Heim nach Schweden.
Am Bodensee bei Familie Tokay.
Der Wagen da, Anniki?
- Den brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Da bist du auch mal dringesessen.
- Er ist bequem.
20 Fr.
- Gut, also.
Der Schlitten? - Das ist
ein schöner Davoser Schlitten.
Der ist da vorne ein wenig kaputt.
Aber ja,
dann gibst du ihn halt für 10 Fr.
Wir verkaufen unseren Hausrat
und sonst alles, was im Haus war.
Mal schauen, wie viele Leute kommen
und wie viel wir loswerden
oder dann entsorgen müssen.
Das Haus in Steckborn
hat die Familie schon verkauft.
Jetzt wollen die Tokays
noch überflüssigen Hausrat loswerden,
bevor sie in Südafrika neu starten.
So, was haben wir jetzt gesagt? 900.
Also wenn jemand fragt,
dann weisst du es? - Ja.
Diese Stühle.
Und dann gibt es noch Polster dazu.
Sie sind einfach
nicht mehr so schön.
Die Tokays kennen Südafrika.
Doris war regelmässig
mit ihrem Tibi dort.
Schon als Jugendlicher
lebte er knapp sieben Jahre lang
mit seinen Eltern am Kap.
Südafrika
ist schon lange eine zweite Heimat.
Für mich selber seit 25 Jahren
und für Tibi natürlich sowieso.
Die Vorstellung, nach Italien oder
England auszuwandern, wäre Horror.
Das wäre für mich unvorstellbar.
Bei Südafrika kennt man ungefähr
die Schwierigkeiten und Chancen.
Und da müssen wir uns
ein wenig absprechen.
Aus dem Einfamilienhaus
auf die Farm bei Kapstadt:
Tokays wollen bald
Gäste bewirten und beherbergen.
Ich weiss gar nicht,
die wollte ich mitnehmen.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
Doris hat sie hier hingelegt.
Genau, die nehmen wir mit.
Der Stuhl? - Der rote?
- Ja. - Den will Anniki behalten.
Nein, der ledrige.
Was für ein ledriger? - Der,
auf den man die Beine legen kann.
Den möchte ich behalten.
Bist du sicher?
- Ja.
Der passt eigentlich gut
zum Polster.
Wenn jemand unbedingt den Stuhl
will, dann geben wir ihn auch.
Aber sonst nehmen wir ihn mit.
- Wie viel, 200 Fr.?
Ich weiss nicht, was der kostete.
- Das ist sehr viel.
Nein, ich weiss auch nicht, 90 Fr.?
- Nein, ehrlich? 100 Fr.?
Also komm, wir nehmen ihn mit.
- Okay, gut.
Der siebenjährige Mika
und die elfjährige Anniki
haben ein paar Spielsachen
aussortiert.
Die Auswanderer haben
in der Lokalzeitung annonciert,
ihren Freunden und Bekannten
Bescheid gesagt
und die Nachbarn informiert.
Grüezi, wir haben Flohmarkt -
falls Sie Lust haben vorbeizukommen,
einfach die Treppe hoch,
es gibt ganz viel Ware.
Hallo zusammen - so schön!
Kommt ihr von der Badi?
Wir sind schon ganz nervös.
Hoi, die Kinder
freuen sich auch, euch zu sehen.
Schau, der Nächste. Da kommen alle.
Das ist gut -
und einfach nicht ins Garagentor.
Ja ja -
Es ist ja eh das unserer Nachbarn.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Bezahlt.
Die Besucher
haben einiges mitgenommen.
Trotzdem
bleibt noch viel für Südafrika.
Liestal:
Stefano Lotti und Stefano Navarretta
sind ein eingespieltes Team:
beste Freunde und Geschäftspartner.
Er wischt immer.
Stefano Navarretta hat freitags
seinen festen Termin beim Barbier.
Stefano Lotti begleitet ihn.
Amico mio!
- Amico mio!
Saluti, wie geht's?
- Gut, gut!
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut und ihr? - Ja, nicht schlecht.
Alles gut, amico. Machst du uns
heute ein wenig schön? - Sicher, ja.
Ich brauche einen Ali-Ferrari-Bart,
du weisst.
Die Stühle sind frei.
- Sehr schön.
Machst du ihn zuerst.
Mein Lieblingsstuhl.
* Wohliger Seufzer *
Seit ihrer Jugend
kennen sich Stefano und Stefano.
Zusammen haben die Baselbieter
eine Personalagentur aufgebaut.
Die Firma lief gut.
Trotzdem zieht es sie weg:
nach Mexiko.
Ich friere schnell, obwohl ich
in der Schweiz geboren bin.
Aber mit der Kälte
kann ich nicht so gut umgehen.
Wenn die Möglichkeit besteht,
an der Wärme zu leben,
dann will ich die Gelegenheit
so gut es geht nutzen.
Oh, Ali, ich habe immer geträumt,
einmal zu gehen
und neue Erfahrungen zu machen.
Jetzt ist es so weit.
Jetzt geht es wirklich
nicht mehr lange.
Sag Bescheid, wenn es gut ist,
dann komme ich auch.
In Mexiko vertraut Stefano zunächst
auf einen sicheren Job.
Er steigt als Geschäftsführer
in der Firma seines Onkels ein.
Initiiert hat es Stefano.
Mexiko hat den Vorteil, dass wir
zu seiner Familie gehen können.
Das ist natürlich die Luxusvariante
vom Auswandern.
Ich hatte schon
als Kind die Sehnsucht,
etwas anderes zu sehen
und irgendwo hinzugehen.
Nun hat es sich ergeben.
Man weiss nie, was das Leben bringt.
So, Stefano, jetzt machen wir mal
im Sitzen weiter. - Mhm.
Ali, was hätte ich nur gemacht
ohne diesen Ferrari-Bartschnitt?
Was hätte ich
diese sechs Jahre nur gemacht?
Jetzt kann nichts schiefgehen.
Ohne deinen Bart hätte ich mind.
50 % weniger Freundinnen gehabt.
Und 50 % weniger Umsatz auch noch.
Was hätte ich ohne dich gemacht!
Grande Ali, grande.
Ausserdem wollen die beiden dort
mit Immobilien handeln.
Ihr Startkapital ist das Geld,
das sie mit ihrer Personalagentur
gemacht haben.
Aber Ali, bitte mach ihn nicht
zu schön, ich brauche ihn noch.
Nicht, dass er wegen aller Frauen
in Mexiko nicht mehr arbeiten will.
Ich mache ihn ein bisschen schräg.
* Lachen *
Ettiswil im Wauwilermoos.
Markus Buob ist gelernter Schreiner.
Schon seit 7 Uhr
steht er in der Werkstatt.
Sein Auftrag heute:
Türrahmen im Akkord zusammensetzen.
In Schweden ist es so,
dass man sich auch als normaler
Arbeiter etwas leisten kann.
Diese Chance haben wir
in der Schweiz einfach nicht mehr.
Ausserdem ist Schweden
ein sehr schönes Land.
Sie sind mehr naturverbunden,
sie leben mehr mit der Natur.
D.h., im Winter wird auch mal
einen Gang runtergeschalten.
Und ich glaube,
bei uns ist es nicht mehr so.
Bei uns wird auf Weihnachten
eher einen Gang höher geschalten.
* Aufmüpfige Musik *
In Schweden wartet ein Hof am See
auf die junge Familie.
Markus und seine Frau haben ihn auf
einer ihrer vielen Reisen entdeckt.
Jetzt kann Markus jede freie Minute
für die Vorbereitung gebrauchen.
Schönen Mittag.
Die Tage zählen wir noch nicht.
Aber demnächst gibt es
wahrscheinlich einen Countdown,
wo wir dann irgendwann
anfangen zu packen und dann los.
Ich darf auch nicht erzählen,
wie sehr ich mich freue.
Sonst ist meine Familie
irgendwann mal beleidigt.
Das wäre ein wenig doof.
Hier haben Markus und Sylvia
vor drei Jahren noch gearbeitet:
im Renovationsfachbetrieb
von Sylvias Eltern.
Diese wollten die Firma
an die Auswanderer übergeben.
Ich kenne ein paar, die das Geschäft
vom Vater übernommen haben.
Dies, weil man es so machen sollte.
Und ich weiss,
sie sind nicht glücklich.
Es gibt ganz viele, die lieber
etwas anderes machen würden,
als den elterlichen Betrieb
zu übernehmen, aber das ist halt so.
Es stimmt für uns,
das ist das Wichtige.
Ich meine
wir müssen ja unser Leben leben.
Fast vier Jahre lang
versuchten Markus und Sylvia,
den Erwartungen der Familie
gerecht zu werden.
Ein sehr schöner Kronleuchter,
aber ...
... ich glaube für Schweden, ja.
Sylvia leitete im Betrieb
die Finanzen, den Showroom
und organisierte die Ausstellungen.
Hallo!
- Hoi.
Markus war Geschäftsführer.
Warst du mit dem Hund unterwegs?
Beide gaben Vollgas in ihren Jobs.
Ich merkte dann v.a. bei Markus,
dass es ihm nicht gut ging.
Irgendwann zwingt einen das Leben,
auch ein wenig hinzuschauen.
Wir mussten uns eingestehen, dass
es nicht das ist, was wir wollen.
Und diese Kronleuchter
möchte ich eigentlich verkaufen.
Dann müsste man den auspacken
zum Fotografieren.
Das ist auch schon alt,
den habe ich gekauft, als ...
Nein, die haben wir gekauft,
als wir zusammengezogen sind.
Ja, also, vor zehn Jahren.
Unser Geschmack hat sich
extrem verändert, stelle ich fest.
Meine Güte Schatz,
ist das kitschig.
Damals war es schön.
Da lebten wir im Aargau,
daher war es schön.
Willst du den
da unten im Keller fotografieren?
Sollen wir ihn nicht
an einem Ort in Szene setzen?
Z.B. auf diesen Reifen?
- Ja, auf den Ersatzpneus.
Die Kaffeemaschine nehme ich mit,
das Brotkörbli - alles parat.
Doris bricht in Steckborn auf
zu ihrem letzten Tag im Büro.
Ehemann Tibor
bleibt mit den Kindern zu Hause.
Anniki meinte, heute mache sie
nicht das Mittagessen.
Aha ja, das ist gut,
kein Problem.
Aber es gibt genug, was du schnell
machen kannst. Reste haben wir auch.
Ich denke, ich bin zwischen
15 und 15.30 Uhr da. - Okay.
Ist das gut?
- Das muss gut sein.
Tschüss!
- Tschüss!
Viel Spass.
Doris' Ehemann
ist selbstständiger IT-Consultant,
hat aber bewusst schon länger
keine Aufträge mehr angenommen.
Der 50-Jährige kümmert sich v.a.
um ihr Projekt in Südafrika.
Die Farm im kapholländischen Stil
ist riesig:
Allein der Umschwung
ist so gross wie 60 Fussballfelder.
Wir sind durchgefahren,
ausgestiegen, dort angekommen
und wir wussten eigentlich,
das ist es.
Ohne von der Farm
noch mehr gesehen zu haben.
Es war wie ein Ankommen,
wenn man so will.
Das Anwesen kostet rund 1,1 Mio. Fr.
Hinzu kommt noch die Renovation,
zu viel für Familie Tokay allein.
Wir unterschrieben den Vertrag
im Wissen,
für das Unternehmen
einen Partner zu haben.
Wir hatten einen Investor,
der uns weiterhalf.
Ich muss betonen: hatten,
weil er uns in letzter Minute
abgesprungen ist.
Es hat nicht mit dem Projekt zu tun,
es waren persönliche Beweggründe.
Ja, wir sind nun
auf Hochtouren daran,
einen adäquaten Ersatz zu suchen.
Aber das ist jetzt zum heutigen
Zeitpunkt noch nicht gelöst.
Ja.
Tokays brauchen dringend
einen neuen Geldgeber,
denn es gibt kein Zurück.
Doris arbeitete die letzten sieben
Jahre bei der Kantonspolizei Thurgau,
in der Fachstelle
für häusliche Gewalt.
Hoi!
Vielen Dank.
Sie leitete ein Team
mit vier Mitarbeitern.
Du hast es gut?
- Ja, es ist schon streng.
Und es gibt auch
gewisse Unsicherheiten.
Es ist nicht so, dass du alles
bestellt hast und dann gehst du.
Von daher ... Wobei die letzten
Nächte schlief ich wunderbar,
weil ich einfach so müde war,
dass ich nur noch schlafe.
Die ungewisse Zukunft
braucht Kraft.
Doris hat schon viel gemacht,
aber der Job war immer sicher:
als Schriftenmalerin,
als Sozialarbeiterin im Strafvollzug
und bei der Jugendanwaltschaft.
Also hier
bin ich am längsten gewesen
von allen Arbeitsbereichen,
wo ich jemals war.
Das heisst viel,
aber für mich war klar,
ich will noch etwas anderes machen.
Für mich ist das auch gesund.
Aber ich wäre sicher noch ein paar
Jahr geblieben, das ist klar.
Gerade in der Leitung hätte ich noch
einiges gewusst anzustellen.
Das wird von meiner Kollegin
gut weitergemacht.
Der Computer
lässt mich nicht mehr rein.
Ja, ein Zeichen zum Gehen.
Raus aus der Sicherheit:
Den Weg in die Selbstständigkeit
macht die 45-Jährige zum ersten Mal.
Gehen wir rein.
Es sollte ja alles geputzt sein.
Stefano und Stefano lösen ihre Firma
in der Schweiz endgültig auf.
Das Zweifamilienhaus in Niederdorf
war ein Teil ihres Geschäftes.
So.
Herzlich willkommen!
Die beiden Stefanos
haben ausländische Handwerker
auf Baustellen
in der Schweiz vermittelt.
Etliche ihrer Leiharbeiter
haben sie hier untergebracht.
Früher
war hier unten eine Werkstatt.
Wir übernahmen
und renovierten das Haus,
um den Leuten
eine Unterkunft bieten zu können.
Sie sind aus ganz Europa gekommen:
Spanien, Ungarn, Polen -
überall,
wo es willige Arbeitskräfte gab,
die in der Schweiz arbeiten wollten,
um so ihre Familie zu unterstützen.
Über 70 Handwerker
hatten die beiden unter Vertrag.
Anfangs vermittelten wir die Leute
fremd an Hotels und Unterkünfte
und ohne etwas daran zu verdienen.
Dann entstand die Idee für den
Hauskauf oder eine Liegenschaft,
um auch ein Stück vom Kuchen
zu haben.
Dann kam dieses Haus,
und wir haben es umgebaut.
Jetzt kommt das Nächste,
denn die Zukunft ist in Mexiko.
Ja, das ist so.
Das Haus wollten sie noch sanieren.
Aber dann haben sie
einen Interessenten gefunden,
der es so übernimmt, wie es ist.
Jetzt hält die beiden
nichts mehr in der Schweiz.
Die Personalagentur
ist schon verkauft.
Bis zu ihrem Start in Mexiko
haben sie sich
ein provisorisches Büro eingerichtet,
dies bei Stefano Navarettas Mutter.
Hat es Buchungen gegeben?
- Warte ...
Ach ja, schau an.
Dieses Hostel in Kuba verwalten wir
von hier aus für meinen Onkel.
Das sind die heutigen Buchungen,
die reingekommen sind.
Von gestern auf heute hatten wir
sechs Buchungen - das ist super.
Der Onkel ist sehr zufrieden,
weil er es mir in Auftrag gab,
als es gar nicht gelaufen ist.
Er meinte es sei die Möglichkeit,
mich zu beweisen,
bevor ich komme und zeige,
was ich kann.
Dies haben wir umgesetzt.
Stefano Lotti
hat eine neue Buchungsplattform
für das Hostel in Kuba eingerichtet -
als gelernter Informatiker
ist das sein Ding.
Sein Kollege übernimmt jetzt
den Kontakt mit den Kunden.
Wenn das gut läuft, wäre es
ein gelungener Einstand in Mexiko.
Ah, so muss es richtig tönen.
* Kaffeemaschinengeräusch *
Die beiden wollen aber auch
eigene Geschäfte machen:
Land kaufen, Wohnungen bauen
und an reiche Ausländer verkaufen -
so der Plan.
Wir werden sehen, was sich ergibt.
Wir haben Interessenten,
die dort mit uns investieren wollen.
Es ist klar, dass wir sie zuerst
auch vor Ort überzeugen müssen.
Das braucht alles ein bis drei
Jahre, bevor es konkret wird.
Aber so haben wir
ein daily business,
um herauszufinden, wie der Markt
und die Ämter funktionieren
und was man an Steuern zahlen muss.
Man beginnt zu verstehen, wie
das Geschäft in Mexiko funktioniert.
Du musst noch Baschki anrufen
wegen der Besichtigung am Samstag.
Diese ist nicht am Freitag.
- Ja. - Super.
Regentage in Schötz im Kanton Luzern.
Das Abschiedsfest für die Auswanderer
wird bei den Schwiegereltern
von Markus vorbereitet.
Schwiegervater Theo
hilft mit dem Regenschutz.
Sie haben 40 Leute eingeladen:
Freunde, Bekannte
und Sylvias Geschwister.
Es ist ein lang ersehntes Fest.
Es bedeutet, der Countdown
ist eingeläutet, und wir gehen bald.
Im Haus der Schwiegereltern
gibt es genügend Platz.
Die Wohnung von Sylvia und Markus
ist zu klein und voller Zügelkartons.
Was soll ich machen?
- Du kannst Spiessli machen aus ...
Theo hat Mühe damit, seine Tochter
nicht mehr in der Nähe zu haben.
Der Plan war, dass Markus und Sylvia
das Geschäft weiterführen.
Bis zur Sitzung, als sie
ihre Zukunftspläne erläuterten -
nämlich gerne auszuwandern.
Das Auswandern
hat mich nicht mal so überrascht,
da sie schon immer
Weltenbummler waren.
Von daher ...
Ich hatte nichts gespürt, dass es
in diese Richtung gehen könnte.
In diesem Moment war es schon hart.
Muss du jetzt die Zigarren
auspacken,
wenn ich da den Kuchen mache?
Das ist doch kein Problem,
hier noch die Utensilien.
Da.
Theo konnte die Firma mittlerweile
an einen Mitarbeiter verkaufen.
Aber hinzunehmen,
dass Sylvia und Markus
sie nicht weiterführen wollten, fiel
ihm und seiner Frau Beatrice schwer.
Es war ein Prozess,
bis wir dies akzeptieren konnten.
Sie hätten sehr gut in die Firma
gepasst und haben es super gemacht.
Ehrlich gesagt, waren wir schon
ein wenig enttäuscht.
Wir gaben ihrem Glück
einfach immer Vorrang.
Fondue ... Kuchen ...
- Ja.
* Türklingel *
Guten Tag, hoi!
- Hoi!
Jetzt aber zählt nur noch
ihr neues Zuhause in Schweden.
Und die Freunde
freuen sich mit ihnen.
Liebe Sylvia, lieber Markus,
Mami und ich haben euch
noch ein kleines Geschenk.
Ein kleines Schiff, und wir hoffen,
dass ihr in ruhigen Gewässern -
der See ist sicher ruhig da oben -
aber dass ihr auch neben dem See
in ruhigen Gewässern unterwegs seid,
und wir wünschen euch alles Gute.
Vielen Dank, ist mega lieb.
* Gefühlvolle Klänge *
Noch einmal hoch hinaus.
Tibi, ist Mika eingecremt?
- Ja, Mika ist eingecremt.
Mami,
sind meine Beine gut eingecremt?
Hinten noch. Dreh dich!
Oder habe ich da schon?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, anders rum.
Nun kannst du selber schmieren.
Bevor Tibor, Doris und die Kinder
nach Südafrika aufbrechen,
haben sie ein letztes Mal
die Familie um sich versammelt:
die Eltern von Doris und
ihre Schwester mit Mann und Kindern.
Dort müssen wir rechts abbiegen.
Meinst du, das ist dieser Weg? - Ja.
Doch, doch.
Wieso hast du
die Schweizer Fahne dabei?
Wir hätten die südafrikanische
Fahne mitnehmen sollen.
Vom Crap Sogn Gion oberhalb von Flims
wandern sie zur Alphütte Nagens.
Da hinten ist der Maseign.
- Ja, das sehe ich auch.
Und wir müssen hier schräg hinüber.
Wir hätten ebenso den schönen Weg
statt diesen hier gehen können.
Also schau, wir müssen ganz klar
bei dieser Hütte vorbei.
Wir zweigen erst
ein wenig weiter oben ab.
Oder?
An jeder Abzweigung
gilt eine Neuorientierung.
Aber das ist bei uns nicht ganz neu,
es ist immer gut gekommen.
Es ist wunderschön dort,
es ist mega schön.
Seid ihr alle da? Los!
* Antreibende Musik *
Ein wenig aufpassen hier, ups.
Weiterlaufen!
Willst du nicht? Ein Brötli?
Wir haben es hier in der Schweiz
ja schön.
Gleichzeitig merken wir,
dass wir so in unserem Haus sind.
Wir arbeiten für unser Haus.
Wie es viele um uns herum auch tun.
Es ist für uns
fast ein wenig langweilig.
Fast ein bisschen so:
Du kannst nun einfach arbeiten,
bis du pensioniert bist
und dann nimmt es den Lauf der Dinge
oder man wagt nochmal etwas Neues.
So einfach zusammenkommen,
dies wird für die Familie
bald nicht mehr gehen.
* Handorgelklänge *
Und schon jetzt ist die Wehmut gross.
# So friedlich und schön ...
V.a. bei den Grosseltern.
Der müde Mika!
* Lachen *
Ja, nun müssen wir uns
ein neues Hobby suchen,
weil wir die Enkel nicht mehr haben.
- Ja!
Die Kinder waren oft bei uns,
wir vermissen sie sicher.
Ja, ich hätte es mir nicht
gewünscht, muss ich sagen.
Es ist schade.
Uff ...
Stefano Lotti räumt sein Zimmer
im Haus seiner Eltern.
In zwei Tagen
geht der Flieger nach Mexiko.
Seine eigene Wohnung hat der 31-
Jährige schon vor Monaten aufgegeben.
Ja, jetzt wird das Zimmer
wieder leer.
Es ist einfach ...
Mutter Anita hilft packen.
Jetzt kann man es
wieder anders nutzen. - Ja ja!
Gell, bis du wieder
nach Hause kommst.
Wenn ich wieder herkomme,
stelle ich im Garten ein Zelt auf.
Nein, du kannst schon hier schlafen,
ich mache wieder das Bett.
Das ist aber lieb, danke! - Ich bin
froh, wenn ich dich wiedersehe.
Ehrlich gesagt
ist es nicht so ein gutes Gefühl,
aber ich kann es nicht ändern -
es ist nun einfach so.
Aber ich weiss, dass es für sie
sicher nicht so schön ist.
Sie ist ein Mensch,
der nicht so einfach loslassen kann
und sich v.a. Sorgen macht.
Aber ich gebe mir Mühe,
ihr keinen Grund zur Sorge zu geben,
wenn ich dort bin.
Jetzt kommt es drauf an,
ob es Platz hat.
Lange Sachen
brauche ich ja nicht viel,
ich habe schon etwas ausgemistet
und einen Kleidersack gemacht -
deswegen muss ich mal schauen,
was da ist.
Du musst ein wenig anders falten.
Ja ja, lass es mich einfach machen.
- Ja, ich lass dich.
Es ist ja nicht das erste Mal,
dass ich einen Koffer packe.
Die beiden Stefanos verlassen
die Heimat ohne grosses Fest.
In den letzten Wochen
haben sie sich schon nach und nach
von den Freunden und Kollegen
verabschiedet.
Aber heute
steht noch ein wichtiger Termin an.
Er ist schon in der Küche
und trinkt Neocitran.
Geschäftspartner Stefano muss mit -
trotz Erkältung.
Geht's besser, Alter? - Ja, es geht,
es hat mich gerade noch erwischt.
Kontaktpflege ist angesagt -
Networking -
Stefano Navarrettas Stärke.
Sie sind da.
Die beiden, die sie besuchen,
sind alte Bekannte
und könnten für Mexiko
wichtig werden.
Ja, hallihallo, Maestros!
- Wie geht's?
Gut und selber? - Wunderbar,
darf nicht klagen, danke.
Pasci, wie geht es dir?
- Gut, dir auch? Schön seid ihr da.
Ja sieht man, wie immer
alles frisch. - Bald geht es los.
Pascal Siegrist und Claudio Iannuzzi
sind zu Geld gekommen:
mit Versicherungen und Hanfläden.
Die Auswanderer hoffen, dass die
beiden später bei ihnen investieren.
Wir freuen uns wirklich für euch.
Das ist schön, wir warten auf euch.
- Wir kommen garantiert.
Ja, jetzt ist es so weit.
Zum Abschied zaubert Pascal Hoch-
prozentiges aus seinem Sportwagen.
Ja!
Das ist ja ein Witz, oder?
- Nein!
Nein! - Ganz symbolisch,
mit einem mexikanischen Hütchen.
Du weisst aber schon,
dass dies der Müll-Tequila ist?
Ja, es ist nicht wegen der Qualität,
sondern wegen des Hütchens.
Vielen Dank, Pasci. - Behaltet ihn
auf, er ist mehr symbolisch.
Wir kommen runter
und leeren ihn zusammen -
plus noch einen echten von unten.
- Ja, das ist gut.
Alles Gute!
- Mach's gut.
Bald geht es
1'600 km Richtung Norden.
Markus und Sylvia
räumen in Wauwil ihre Wohnung.
So, erst einmal ausladen.
Das ist eine Birkendekoration
des Eingangs vom alten Geschäft.
Da kommen Blumentöpfe rein.
Ich finde es etwas komisch,
Birken nach Schweden mitzubringen.
Alles muss in den kleinen Lkw passen.
Sie dürfen mit,
wenn wir noch Platz haben.
Den Umzug nach Schweden organisieren
die Buobs mit Familie und Freunden.
Ist es gut?
- Super.
In wenigen Tagen haben sie die
Dreizimmerwohnung an der Bahnstrecke
hinter sich gelassen
und wohnen in ihrem Hof am See.
Auch wenn noch nicht
alles perfekt ist.
Wir konnten den Kauf
noch nicht 100 % abschliessen
und warten nun noch
auf den Vermessungsingenieur.
Wenn er dann kommt,
können wir nach über einem Jahr
endlich den Kauf abschliessen.
Also wir mussten uns
über ein Jahr gedulden.
Jetzt können sie endlich einziehen,
der Verkäufer hat sein Okay gegeben -
obwohl der Handwechsel noch nicht
im Grundbuch eingetragen ist.
Besitzer ihres Hauses
werden sie erst,
wenn das Grundstück in Schweden
neu vermessen ist.
Im ganzen Prozess,
in dem wir jetzt stecken,
war es eine schöne Erfahrung
zu merken,
dass man die Ungewissheit
der Unzufriedenheit bevorzugt.
Und wenn man die Möglichkeit hat,
seinen Traum zu leben ...
... ist es plötzlich
ein angenehmes Gefühl.
Ja ja -
du kannst die Schublade bringen.
Die Ruhe von Schweden
ist zum Greifen nah.
In Liestal sind nur Mutter Ammelia
und ihr Partner
zum Abschied gekommen.
Ready?
- I'm ready!
Was hast du?
Das musst du mitnehmen und soll dir
Glück bringen. - Danke vielmals!
Stefano ist Ammelias einziges Kind.
Diese Mütze habe ich ihm gemacht,
denn als Bub nannte ich ihn Titti.
Er bekommt einen speziellen Platz.
Mit der Bahn
reisen die Jungs nach Kloten.
Non ti preoccupare. Es kommt
alles gut, mach dir keine Sorgen.
Es kommt alles gut.
Dann geht es -
nur mit ein paar Koffern -
über Frankfurt
weiter in die Karibik.
Danke schön für alles!
* Melancholische Klänge *
Paparazzi! Groupies und alles!
Schauen, lächeln!
Familie Tokay fliegt in 1 Std.
nach Südafrika.
Wo ist Nügel?
Los! Tschau. Okay! - Jetzt habe ich
die Hüte, die ich nicht wollte.
So.
Tschüss!
- Tschüss, Lena!
(Alle) Tschüss!
Es ist eine Reise ins Ungewisse -
ans andere Ende der Welt.
Rund 9'000 km -
immer Richtung Süden.
* Afrikanischer Gesang *
Lobgesänge ...
Flüsse und Hügel ...
Die Big Five ...
Fröhliche Tänze ...
Schönes, liebenswertes Afrika.
Ich habe ja als Kind
einige Jahre hier gelebt.
Wir sind zwischendrin immer
regelmässig wieder zurückgekommen.
Also das Retourkommen
ist sehr vertraut.
* Afrikanischer Gesang *
Boah!
-Das ist schon krass, oder?
Ein richtiges Feuerwerk.
- Wahnsinn.
Also, gehen wir weiter.
- Ja.
Oggi, nach fünf Jahren,
haben wir es geschafft.
Grazie a te.
Auf diesen Tag haben die Stefanos
lange hingearbeitet.
Hier rechts, oder Ste?
Da ist das schöne Haus.
Die erste Nacht in Mexiko -
in der Villa von Stefanos Onkel.
* Unverständliches Stimmengewirr *
Fernando Navarretta
ist Geschäftsmann.
Seit mehr als zehn Jahren
lebt der Onkel hier in Cancún.
Fernando!
Alles in Ordnung?
- Alles gut.
Wie letztes Mal?
- Nein perfekter Flug, alles gut.
Hola. Uno, dos? - Uno.
- Hola, mucho gusto! - Hola Lesley!
Buonasera!
- Buonasera!
Come stai?
- Bene e tu?
- Bene. - Sono tre,
come in Svizzera, okay? - Ja.
Mein Onkel hat ein grosses Herz
und er teilt dieses gerne
mit verschiedenen Frauen -
sagen wir es so.
Salute, Stefano.
- Salute.
Ja, auf Mexiko.
- Auf Mexiko, auf unsere Zukunft.
In der nächsten Folge:
Familie Tokay muss ihre Pläne
mit der Farm aufgeben.
Wir haben uns
mit dem Besitzer getroffen,
wurden uns aber nicht einig.
Sie sind raus aus der Langeweile -
unerwarteter Stress.
Jetzt gehst du hier raus, sofort!
Ciao Baby, tschüss!
Für die Buobs
soll ein neues Leben beginnen.
Perfektes Glück in Schweden?
Pipa, jetzt bist du daheim.
- Ja, was.
Und in Mexiko
muss Stefano in der Firma gleich ran.
Mein Onkel hat mir nun eigentlich
die Vollmacht gegeben,
damit ich für ihn
alles unterschreiben darf.
Zwei verschiedene Welten -
Arm trifft auf Reich.
Aber genau hier wollen die Jungs
Geld mit Immobilien machen.
Die ersten zehn Seiten waren einfach
tote Leute. Und dann kam der Sport.